Hi, I'm Mike LaBruno,
owner of All-Brite
Pressure Washing & More.
We specialize in gutter cleaning
and pressure washing
of homes and businesses
in southeast North Carolina.
I'm going to show you how we clean
clogged gutters before winter.
In the fall, we're going to have
a lot of leaves and debris that fall,
so it's important to check your gutters
before a snowstorm.
If we have snow that
accumulates on a roof,
we can have some water runoff.
As temperatures rise, that snow will melt,
causing excessive rainwater
to flow into the gutter
and freeze and unfreeze,
potentially causing water to expand
back up into the interior of your home
underneath the roofline,
We start by inspecting gutters
by removing any debris from the roof.
Dry debris consists of leaves, dirt,
and shingle grit, which can cause
excessive weight inside of the gutter too.
A pressure washer is a great tool
for cleaning out gutters,
but if it's too compacted,
we will first need to
resort to handpicking this.
We want to pick out as
many clumps and clogs,
wet or dry debris, as we can.
Wet debris is just a little bit muddier,
and we have water added with it,
which is excessive weight
inside of the gutter,
stressing it out.
If we find a big clog,
such as wet compacted debris,
in some cases, we have to
take the downspout apart.
We will start at the bottom
by removing rivets or screws
to get closer to our clog or backup.
Once we're done handpicking
all the debris we can,
we want to perform our flush test.
This is where we will
take a pressure washer
and run water in the top of the gutter
towards the downspout
for at least 10 to 20 seconds.
We want to remove any remaining debris
that we did not get from handpicking,
and we want to see good,
clear flow of water
diverting away from the
home and foundation.
We will start at the top of the gutter
and then move to the downspout
to ensure we have no remaining debris
and everything is flowing correctly.
If we see clear water and good flow
and hear a hollow sound,
there are no clogs present.
If there is a clog present,
we want to tap on that downspout
and determine where the clog is.
We want to run water
through the top of the downspout
and have someone at the bottom
checking to make sure that debris
is starting to flow through.
Here, this is all pine straw
that's been collecting for
at least a couple years.
We are using a tap-shake method
along with running water
in the top of the gutter
to break up the debris
and flush out all of the pine straw.
A good way to tell
that your gutters are flowing properly
is there will be no water running
over the top of the gutter
and you will see clear water
at the bottom of the downspout.
Depending on the type of tree
and location of landscaping
around your home
will determine how often
you should clean your gutters out
and what type of debris may fall in them.
A good practice would be
to trim back trees as needed
and plant future trees
further away from the home.